au lendemain d'élections
la première femme élue à la tête de
montréal est accueilli en vendée c'est
la fin des millions de dollars investis
dans la course de formule électrique
madame la mairesse de montréal valérie
plantes mais la lune de miel prend fin
abruptement avec un bris de promesse une
hausse de taxes salée chaque
administration prandelli fait des choix
valérie plantes admettra l'erreur 24
heures plus tard messieurs d'abord cette
promesse brisée j'ai je dois prendre
acte et dire la façon dont on l'a
communiqué n'était pas la bonne c'était
une erreur de ne pas le communiqué dans
son tout ici sur le dépliant qui on me
donne ma porte
moins de taxes pour les familles alors
quand j'y vis or certains je vote pour
elle ce citoyen du quartier saint-michel
en veut encore à la mairesse madame
valérie plantes à la vad l'air car une
personne économique qui est à pour
baisser ou contrôler des taxes est à la
fête la contraire c'est très fort cher
très fort cher mais d'autres saluent un
changement de gouvernance à l'hôtel de
ville
j'ai voté pour valérie toute l'équipe et
je suis très satisfait de mon vote
parce que on a enfin une administration
qui est en même temps une administration
proximité et une administration qui est
capable de gérer les gros dossiers et
ils sont profondément transports je vous
cacherais pas mon enthousiasme ans et
mon plaisir de faire cette annonce ce
matin valérie plantes et son équipe ont
honoré la majorité des engagements pris
pour la première année au coeur de ses
promesses un investissement massif dans
le transport en commun dont
l'acquisition accéléré de 300 autobus
hybrides run à l'administration coderre
on avait une baisse de l'offre de
service la stm on n'est pas du tout dans
cette optique là on est vers une
croissance des services de la stm à
montréal avec l'achat de trois nouveaux
autobus c'est un match historique en
tant qu'administration nous avons décidé
de nous donner les moyens de retenir et
d'attirer davantage de familles à
montréal
le programme d'accès à la propriété est
un autre exemple de réalisation
les familles peuvent obtenir jusqu'à
15000 dollars de subventions pour
l'achat d'une résidence
si l'administration assume toujours
certaines politiques qui ont créé des
remous réduction de la circulation
automobile ou autorisation d'avoir des
pitbulls il y a des dossiers moins
réussies comme les problèmes liés aux
chantiers qui se multiplient à montréal
l'échec premier aux commerçants aux
prises avec des travaux se font toujours
attendre et certains projets piétinent
les travaux rue sainte-catherine accuse
des mois de retard
l'administration plantes à imposer des
critères trop restrictifs aux
entrepreneurs l'appel d'offres vient
d'être relancé pour une deuxième fois
des sources proches du dossier font
remarquer que les bonnes idées de
l'équipe plantes se heurte à une réalité
la lourdeur de l'appareil municipal je
commencerai à 10 ans que madame plantes
se révèle une politicienne aguerrie
femmes très intelligentes ceci étant dit
il reste que peu comme un avion là qui a
pris son altitude que sa vitesse de
croisière
mais il ya des petites l'immergeant sous
le tableau de bord les lumières jaunes
en ce qui me concerne sont
malheureusement la rue sainte-catherine
ici julie marceau radio canada montréal